JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hello.
I've been wanting to try
this for a bit-- 6 billion.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so I've been watching
that work in the keynote
all morning.
I didn't think it
actually worked.
OK, just say a big number.
People start clapping.
That's terrific.
OK, excellent, it
doesn't even have
to have a unit or anything.
ALEX RUSSELL: Hi, hello.
I don't have a big number.
He's Jake Archibald from the
Chrome Developer Relations
team.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And he
is Alex Russell from off
of the full-fat Chrome team.
ALEX RUSSELL: Who
are you calling fat?
We've been working on a new
web standard that gives you
control over the network
stack in the browser.
It opens a bunch of new doors
and exciting possibilities.
And we're excited about them.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
yeah, when you navigate
to a URL in the browser,
a whole lot of stuff
happens under the hood
deep within the browser.
And we were going
to kind of show
a big technical diagram
of how that happened.
But instead, let's throw
dignity to the wind.
And we will visit
the Browserlands,
where over deep within
Interface Valley
a new process has been created.
ALEX RUSSELL: We must
create a window object.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But from where
should I get the markup, sire?
ALEX RUSSELL: Travel on
foot toward the Browserlands
to the HTTP cache.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Shall I take the path
through the haunted
forest of AppCache, sire?
ALEX RUSSELL: No, you fool.
We don't know what
evil lurks there.
Go straight to the HTTP cache,
and ask the forgetful wizard
for the materials that you seek.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
what if he doesn't
have them, because,
say, he forgot?
He is known for that.
ALEX RUSSELL: Then
you must travel
across the Sea of Uncertainty
to the internet, where
the kittens roam freely.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But that is a
treacherous journey, my lord.
I've seen many
requests never return.
ALEX RUSSELL: Nevertheless,
that is your quest.
(WHISPERING) 800
milliseconds later.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I've
returned with markup riches
fresh from the heart
of the internet.
ALEX RUSSELL: Finally.
Oh, we don't have
everything we need
to construct this window object.
I see here that we
need two cases of CSS,
an entire silo of
JavaScript, and seven images.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
it's OK, my lord.
I know the way.
ALEX RUSSELL: No, no, some of
these are from another domain.
You must take a different path.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And when
that CSS comes back,
we'll probably find out
there's loads more stuff
we need to fetch things like
the fonts and extra images.
And every trip you
make to the internet
is fraught with uncertainty.
To go there, you're going for
your connection to the rooter,
first off, then to the ISP
intermediate proxies, and then
the destination server.
You get the response.
And then, you go back
through all of those things.
And if any of that is slow, the
user experience will be slow.
And if any of that fails,
the user experience fails.
The platform didn't actually
give you any control over this.
And for us, that
raised some red flags.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, it really
isn't an extensible place
to be.
We believe that the web
should be extensible,
which is to say that if the
web decides to give you a car,
it should let you
take it apart, mix it
with all kinds of other
things, and build something
truly unique if you want to.
And we think this is
where AppCache went wrong.
AppCache used a
declarative manifest format
that you can control the network
with, but only a little bit.
It was AppCache's
way or the highway.
And if you didn't like
it AppCache's way,
you were sort of out of luck.
And it was never
quite what you wanted.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Mm, yeah.
Also, it wasn't
really clear what
behaviors you would
activate and get
when you added a line
to this manifest format.
It was basically like a grab
bag full of caching, rooting,
versioning, but then topped up
with wasps and razor blades.
And every time you
added a line to this,
you were reaching inside there
and just pulling something out,
usually a wasp full
of razor blades.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, the
problems with AppCache
are something that I
think you've colorfully
expounded upon in the past.
But let's recap very quickly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Right, so I think we're
all up to date on AppCache.
And it's kind of a shame
that it didn't work out.
Because many of the features
inside of the black box that it
presented are really valuable--
caching, routing, versioning.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
yeah, it's no coincidence
that some of the native apps
that I rely on day to day,
they manage the
network to create
an offline first experience
where connectivity
is treated as an enhancement.
And each app does this
slightly differently
in a way that is best
for that particular app.
ALEX RUSSELL: Wait, you
use Twitter offline?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, right.
So you get into an elevator.
What do you do?
ALEX RUSSELL: I talk to someone.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right--
wait, you do what?
ALEX RUSSELL: I talk
to another human being.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, so
I am English, right?
Social engagement in an
enclosed space with nowhere
to run-- no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
No, I hold up my phone
to my face as protection
from your kind, you
elevator socializers.
But it's great.
Because Twitter still opens
even though there's hardly
any signal in an
elevator, right?
And it does it really quickly.
It does offline first
really, really well.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right, well a new
web standard brings all of that
to your phone in the web.
And that new standard
is the ServiceWorker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yay.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yay?
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
that's easy-- brilliant.
ALEX RUSSELL: I should
have used a big number.
This is something we've been
working on with Mozilla,
Samsung, and a load of
other third parties.
And we've been collaborating
with them for a long time now.
And we're really
excited about it.
But enough chat-- let's
see what it actually does.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
ALEX RUSSELL: So here's the
QuizApp from the keynote
that you might have
seen this morning.
And it's all built on the web.
And it has a URL just
like any other website.
So I like this app a lot.
I've been using it for a while.
I'm not very good at it.
But I'm just going to go ahead
and add it to my home screen
so that when I relaunch
it, I have a nice shortcut.
It's QuizApp, yeah, great.
Oh, hey, it's even got
its own icon there.
That's pretty great.
So I'm going to
open that back up.
And let's see-- cool.
If I go to the
leader board, I can
see that Jake is also
playing against me.
We're both yellow cats, though.
Anyhow--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hm,
yeah, nice app, buddy.
But you see, I'm not
really interested in you
getting the same amount of
points as me or overtaking me.
So what would happen if
someone were to-- can
I close all of those?
ALEX RUSSELL: I guess.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah?
And I'm going to break
your connectivity.
What are you going to do now?
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, I guess
I'm just going to keep playing?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh no.
So maybe what we should
do at this point-- so
we've been running
this live demo.
And we've done it this
morning a few times.
And that seem to happen like
once out of every five times.
ALEX RUSSELL: So it is
actually working offline.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It is
ALEX RUSSELL: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, pretend
you didn't see that first bit.
That's great.
That means the next
demo that we do
later on in the talk
will definitely work.
Because this one failed, right?
ALEX RUSSELL: Absolutely.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
absolutely brilliant, OK.
So can you still use
the app in that state?
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, I
just loaded this offline.
And I'm going to keep going.
Gorgonzola is a soft cheese
with blue veins in it.
Yeah, hey, cool, great.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
that worked all offline
absolutely first time.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Brilliant.
ALEX RUSSELL: I
mean second time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
That's excellent.
Good to hear, excellent.
ALEX RUSSELL:
First, second time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
even though the app
is an online social
experience, it
was being protected from
bumps in the road using
the ServiceWorker.
Regardless of the connection
state, everything works.
And it works really fast.
So let's go back
to the slides here.
And you want to put your
phone back on online mode.
So the ServiceWorker spec
is still in development,
as you can see from the
slightly-- first time,
it didn't quite work.
But Chrome and Firefox are hot
on the trail of development
here.
This little microsite
will tell you
the status of various
parts of ServiceWorker.
And if you're wanting
to play with it today,
you'll need a copy of
Chrome Canary, which
is our nightly build.
You'll also need to enable some
flags, the details of which
are all on that site.
Anyway, how did we make this
QuizApp work offline first?
Well, we started by
registering for one
of these new
ServiceWorker things
using just JavaScript
on our page.
The behavior of
ServiceWorker is defined
in this resource, which
is just JavaScript.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right, and by
registering ServiceWorker,
you kind of set up
a base of operations
in the kingdom of
ServiceWorkers.
It's not in Interface Valley.
And it doesn't have a DOM.
So it runs on its own thread.
And once we get it set up, it
can manage requests for pages
and handle resource
fetches, that sort of thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yes, but first we
need to get it ready for action.
So one of the huge
advantages of the web
is that it doesn't have
an install process.
You don't need to install a
website in order to use it.
However, installation
is the point
that native apps use to get
all the resources so they
can use them offline.
So we're going to have our
cake and eat it, right?
The user is already on the site.
They're using it uninterrupted.
But the ServiceWorker,
which is all
happening in the background,
does have an install process.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right, and
you get to participate
in that install process
using the Install event.
It gets thrown to the
ServiceWorker script, which
is downloaded and evaluated
the first time the browser sees
that registration for
the ServiceWorker.
It's your opportunity
to get everything ready
before the ServiceWorker
begins to handle navigations
and control pages.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yeah, and you get
to pass a promise
into this function.
This is an event.waitUntil.
And that promise will define
the length and success
of the installation process.
Because a single
service worker could
be handling many
connections at once,
pretty much everything is async.
To make this easier, promises
arrived in JavaScript in ES6
largely thanks to this guy here.
He did a lot of the work.
And they're already in
Chrome, Firefox, Opera.
And they're making their
way into Safari and IE.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right,
so in synchronous code,
you call a function,
you get a return value,
and then you do
something with it.
And if there are errors, you
can handle them with the try
and catch block.
But what if this doSomething
method was asynchronous?
Well, if it returned a promise,
you could do the same stuff.
The value comes back to
you in the first callback.
And you can handle
errors in another call
back if you'd like.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
you can do loads
more with promises
than just this.
But to go for it would
require a session of its own.
And we're not going to do that.
For the sake of what we're
going to cover today,
all you need to know is that
if something returns a promise,
you can put .then at the end
and pass in a success callback
and a failure callback.
You can also chain these .thens
together to do async things
in a sequence.
And you don't need to provide
both callbacks for each one.
In fact, if you do .catch
and provide a callback,
that's exactly the same as .then
with just a failure callback.
If you want to go into
detail with promises,
and I recommend
you do, check out
this article on HTML5 Rocks.
Every hit that
article gets helps
me justify my employment here.
So do please give it a
few refreshes just for me.
ALEX RUSSELL: (WHISPERING)
He could use them.
So what do we want to do during
this installation process?
Well, I guess we
need to do everything
that we hope is going to be
done by the time our application
gets started again, right?
So because ServiceWorkers
install asynchronously,
it's not preventing the
user from interacting
with your site.
So you can deploy
all the troops.
This is the perfect time
to deal with the internet
and uncertainty.
And you can fetch everything
you need right there.
And then, when you
get all the resources
that you needed, send them
back to your data storage area,
the data keep.
The ServiceWorker has access
to the usual data stores
like IndexedDB and a file system
API, but unfortunately not
local storage.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well,
you say "unfortunately,"
but yeah, local
storage is synchronous.
And reading from
disk synchronously
is just a terrible idea.
It was a real mistake
in the web platform
that we have the API like that.
Think about when
you're driving, and you
get an itch on your arm.
And it's fine, right?
Because you can drive, and
you'll scratch your arm,
and everything's OK.
That's because human
beings are sort
of asynchronous by default.
We can do many things at once.
One thing that humans do
which is largely synchronous
is a sneeze.
So once again, if
you're driving,
and you need to sneeze, there's
a moment, a small moment,
where all you can deal with is
the sneeze and nothing else.
And you just have to kind of
hope that no one dies really.
We must avoid code that
is sneezy for that reason.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, so less
sneezing and no local storage.
It's banished from
the ServiceWorker
Kingdom for everyone's safety.
So don't worry, though.
We have added a new
type of data storage
to the platform to help you deal
with these sorts of resources.
The Cache API lets you store
responses keyed by requests.
It's like the HTTP cache, except
it's unique to your origin.
And it's completely
programmable.
Things are only added, removed,
or updated from these caches
when you add, remove,
or update them.
So in this instance, we're going
to create a named cache called
Static-v1.
And then, we're going to add
the files that we want to it.
They can be from other
origins, so don't
worry if you've put
resources out on the CDN.
For the QuizApp, we
wanted every resource
that it needs to display
to be in this cache--
all the HTML, the CSS, the
JavaScript, and the images.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, and if
my slides change-- come on.
Right, so the methods for doing
all of this, the create method
and the add method,
they return promises.
So they're ideal for passing
to this event.waitUntil method.
So if any of these items in the
cache, if they fail to cache,
the promise will reject.
And therefore, our
installation rejects as well.
And if that happens,
don't worry about it.
You will get another
shot at it later on.
But that means if
the install succeeds,
then we know we
have these items.
They're our dependencies.
They're our installation
dependencies.
So once installation
completes, the ServiceWorker
will start
controlling new pages.
So back in the Browserlands,
deep within Interface Valley,
a new tab opens.
ALEX RUSSELL: We must
create a new window object.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But from where
shall I get the markup, sire?
ALEX RUSSELL: I don't know.
Journey to our forces in
the ServiceWorker Kingdom.
They'll know how to deal
with this conundrum.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And that
services as a Fetch event.
You'll get one of these
for every page request
within the ServiceWorker scope.
But you'll also get it for every
request created by those pages.
So the CSS, the
JavaScripts, the images,
XHR fonts all go through
the ServiceWorker,
even if those requests
are to other domains.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right, and
you get as much information
about those requests as
we can safely give you.
But the really fun part is
being able to hijack the request
and provide your own response.
All you need to do is call the
respondWith method of the event
and provide a response object or
a promise that will eventually
resolve to a response object.
You have absolute freedom
in how you do that.
It's like having a
completely programmable proxy
right there on the client.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right,
so at your disposal,
you have information
about the current request
like the headers,
the URL, et cetera.
You have access to
the data stores,
so IDB file system and this
really helpful Cache API.
You also have access
to Fetch, which
will take a URL or
a request object.
And it'll give you a
promise for a response.
And it doesn't have to be
the same request that you're
currently handling
in the ServiceWorker.
It can be to
anywhere on the web.
We've also got
event.default, which
is a nice helper for just doing
what the browser would normally
do in this instance.
But you can also create
responses just manually
using the response constructor.
And you can pass in
text like we have here,
or you can also pass in a
blob or an array buffer.
ALEX RUSSELL: And I think
the best part about this
is that you don't
have to pick just one.
You can fall back from one
response type to another.
Or you can even race
multiple requests
across the network
to the local disk.
Basically, you
can do whatever it
is that you want to do that's
best for your application.
So for the QuizApp, we
handled most requests
by responding with something
that matches from the cache.
Not everything has a
matching cache entry, though,
such as posting answers
or analytics pings.
So for those, we catch
things without a match.
And then, we go to
the network instead.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So that would work
for the CSS, the JavaScript,
HTML, the image and things,
assets that would
only change shape
if we were making like a
new revision to the app,
if we were sort of releasing
a new version of it.
And there are many
exceptions to this.
In our case, such as the
leader board that you saw,
we wouldn't want to cache the
leader board as installation
and then just always serve
it from the cache like this.
Because it would never update.
And it's a resource that's
going to constantly update.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right, so
let's do something slightly
different for the
leader board requests.
First, we're going to parse
the URL from the ServiceWorker
and the URL from the request.
The URL constructor that
you're looking at there
is fairly new in
the web platform.
But it breaks up URLs into
their component parts,
so no more nasty string
munging to try to match a URL.
If the request URL
is to the same origin
as our ServiceWorker, and
the path is leaderboard.json,
we're going to defer handling
to some other method.
So what should that method do?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So it's
really tempting at this point
to flip things over
and go network first.
Try and get the leader
board from the network.
And if that fails, get
whatever we have in the cache.
But that means showing
nothing to the user
while we wait for
the network to return
or we wait for it
to eventually fail.
And that's a really
weird thing to do
when we know we have information
sitting on the user's device.
So instead, let's load
the shell of the page
directly from the ServiceWorker
straight from the cache.
And then, we're going
to start a spinner
so it's letting the user
know that we haven't quite
finished yet.
And then, we're
going to look to see
if we've got an old version of
the leader board in the cache.
And if we do, we're
going to show it.
And then, we'll
go to the network.
We'll try and get
a fresher version.
If we didn't have anything
in the cache, that's OK.
We'll go just straight
to the network.
And once the network
returns, well, we'll
cache that new response.
And we'll update
the page with it.
And we'll stop the spinner,
because we're done.
Now, if we fail to get
something from the cache,
and the network failed to
return, that's a problem.
We're showing nothing.
In that case, we need to
show some kind of an error.
But if the cache got something,
but the network failed,
we'll just fail
silently at that point.
This is a pretty good
offline experience.
This requires the page
to make two requests, one
that goes to the cache
only, and another one that
goes to the network only.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right,
so how do we do that?
Back on our page, here
are the two requests.
They're identical except
the cache request contains
this magic header.
It doesn't do
anything by default.
We're just tagging the request.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And we
can pick up that tag
over in our ServiceWorker.
So we're going to see if
the request header has
this magic header
that we applied.
And if it's there, we're
going to respond just
with a match from the cache.
So if there's
nothing in the cache,
that's going to get
a rejected promise,
and the request will fail.
But that's exactly what we want.
If that header isn't
there, then we'll
go and get our Static-v1 cache.
And we're going
to ask it to fetch
a fresh version of
the leader board
and store it in the cache.
And if that completes
successfully,
we'll also pipe it
back to the browser.
ALEX RUSSELL: This
is the sort of thing
that you can't really do
with a non-extensible feature
like AppCache.
ServiceWorkers aren't
just a framework
for building things
offline first.
They're a series
of tools that you
can do whatever
you need to with.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
so I don't know, how
about poly-filling
a new image format?
Imagine we could do that.
If the request is
for an image, we're
going to make the
default request.
And if what we get back has
this header, the content
type for this new
amazing image format,
then we'll transcode it to
PNG before sending it back
to the browser to something
that it definitely
already understands.
ALEX RUSSELL: OK, OK, but
let's kick it up a notch.
What about client
side templating?
You could just import your
favorite templating engine
and then look for navigation
requests where the URL contains
/article/.
Then you can fetch that URL with
.json added to the end instead,
read it back as JSON, get
a template from the cache
instead, read the
template as text,
then serve up a custom response
as HTML once you've transformed
the template with the JSON using
the templating engine that we
already imported.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yeah, OK, or we could
respond to every image request
with a picture of a kitten
if, and only if,
it's a Thursday.
ALEX RUSSELL: Huh.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I got the clap.
ALEX RUSSELL: You could even
post messages from your page
back to the ServiceWorker.
That makes it trivial
to implement things
like a safer offline
viewing button.
It lets you have
the user help you
decide what they want to cache.
When we got together and we
designed all these APIs--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Not my line.
Sorry, I thought it
was my line next.
Do carry on.
ALEX RUSSELL: Oh.
When we got together--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I like
speaking, you see.
So it feels really natural
to just talk over you.
ALEX RUSSELL: Sorry.
When we got together and
we designed these APIs,
one of the things we didn't
want to do was weld them down.
It's a mistake
that AppCache made.
It tried to be the shortcut
before really understanding
what the destination was.
So instead, what we're doing is
providing low level tools that
give you the flexibility to
do lots of exciting things,
hopefully stuff we
haven't even imagined yet.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And what's
more, if we look at something
like the AppCache
manifest format,
if you reach into
the AppCache grab bag
and end up with a waspy hand,
which you will because it's
terrible, there's not a lot you
can do other than go and read
the specification and try and
find out why all of that stuff
happened, or convince yourself
that it's actually a browser
bug.
If the ServiceWorker does
something you don't expect,
if it does something you
don't understand, what then?
Well, it's JavaScript, right?
We know how to debug JavaScript.
Even at this early stage,
you can go to Chrome Inspect,
and you'll see
the ServiceWorkers
there right next to
the shared workers.
But you can dive even deeper.
You can go into
ServiceWorker in Tunnels,
which will show you that
all the ServiceWorkers are
running across all the sites.
So you can see
there, it logs there.
But you can even launch
straight into DevTools.
Are from there, you'll
see all console logs.
You can set breakpoints, step
through code line by line,
all the debugging
power that you've
come to expect from DevTools.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, and
this is just the start.
We're also in the process of
adding throttling and offline
connection modes to
DevTools so that you'll
be able to see how things work
with a flaky or nonexistent
connection.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes, so we've
said a lot of exciting stuff.
I think now is the
moment, really,
to tell them about the thing.
ALEX RUSSELL: What thing?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You know
the thing, the catch.
ALEX RUSSELL: OK,
all right, so it
turns out that being able to
control every single network
request to your
origin and the request
that your origin
makes to other origins
is super powerful and awesome.
It's also super
powerful and awesome
for a middle man who might
subvert your ServiceWorker
to do something awesomely
terrible with it.
So yeah, for that
reason, you can only
register for
ServiceWorkers for origins
that are secure, that
are served over HTTPS.
And that's the way that we know
that the ServiceWorker hasn't
been messed with on its
way to your browser.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And this
is a theoretical concern.
I got back from a trip to
Turkey a couple of weeks ago.
And days after I go back,
when I was browsing the web,
I was getting pop-ups
for Turkish sites.
I assume they were adverts.
But I couldn't understand them.
But what had happened is
because I was over there,
I didn't have data.
I didn't have a SIM card.
So I was using lots of free
Wi-Fi in pubs and restaurants.
And at some point, and I don't
know when, some bad player
there, some evil
ISP or evil rooter,
injected pop-up scrips into
a popular CDN copy of jQuery.
And the only way I
could get around that
is to flush the cache.
And that's pretty bad, right?
But it's something I could
actually rescue myself
from by flushing the cache.
You do not want that happening
with the ServiceWorker.
People would get instant control
over many origins at once.
So the HTTPS restriction
is an absolute must.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right,
so the good news
is that local host is
exempt from this policy.
And lots of project hosting
sites like GitHub and App
Engine are providing SSL
hosting for free already.
There's also some certificate
authorities like StartSSL
that are starting
to hand out free SSL
certificates for
your own servers.
But I think the backdrop
here if we step back
just a moment is that in
2014, it's really just
the responsible thing to
do to be serving our users'
data to them encrypted.
So it's time to do that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, indeed.
So the ServiceWorker is
really powerful, as we said.
But everything
we've shown so far
has required the interface
to contact the ServiceWorker.
And then, the ServiceWorker
can spring into action.
But if I look at the native apps
that I rely upon day to day,
these can synchronize
in the background.
They can give me notifications.
Well, we're going to
bring that to the web
as well thanks to these
specifications-- background
sync, Push API, and the
notification specification.
ALEX RUSSELL: Cleverly named.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
These are once again
done by a lot of people
that aren't us, right?
It feels like we're just
taking a lot of credit
for other people's work.
ALEX RUSSELL:
(WHISPERING) We might be.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
basically my career.
So these allow the ServiceWorker
to start up on an interval
or in response to a message
that comes from as far away
as the internet.
And when that happens,
then the ServiceWorker
springs into life.
It can go and fetch
multiple things.
It can synchronize things with
the data keep, its caches,
whether.
And then, the ServiceWorker
can go to the interface
and open a tab or show
something like a notification.
Now, this stuff is
really, really new.
And most of it
isn't in Canary yet.
And despite that, and
despite all common sense,
we're going to do
another live demo.
And this one's going
to work, right?
Let's see-- come on.
This one's going to be fine.
This one requires two phones.
So the first one
had one phone fail.
So two phones is going
to work definitely fine.
ALEX RUSSELL: What
could go wrong?
All right, I'm going
to be over here.
And then-- yeah.
So right, so I've
got the app open.
And I've got connectivity.
Let's say I've got connectivity.
And I've got the
same number of points
as Jake if I look in
the leader board now.
Oh, someone else is playing.
Ooh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ooh, this
is going to mess things up.
So what we need to do
to make this demo work
is I need to get
more than 24 points.
ALEX RUSSELL: OK, so we're
going to need some audience
help to get these answers.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
OK, let's do this.
OK, so Alex here is
on his home screen.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well, yeah, and
I'm going to close Chrome, too.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, you're
going to close the app as well.
We're going to close it.
Thanks whoever was playing that.
You've made things
really easy for us.
Right, OK.
ALEX RUSSELL: Food--
we can do food.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
can do this, OK.
ALEX RUSSELL: We can do food.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: False.
ALEX RUSSELL: False?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I know the
first question that comes up
is false.
I didn't even know what it was.
OK, that's honey,
water, and yeast.
ALEX RUSSELL:
Honey, water, yeast.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
No, no, no, no, no.
ALEX RUSSELL: Oh, no, yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
yeah, exit, right, go, go.
ALEX RUSSELL: That one.
Go.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
I've got 24 points now.
ALEX RUSSELL: Potatoes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK,
is that potatoes?
Excellent.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, 32 points.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: All
right, brilliant, right.
Now come on, come on,
come on, come on, do this.
You can really do this.
So what we need, what we're
requiring at the moment,
is connectivity.
I know a lot of this was about
making things work offline.
But this is the one bit that
requires network connectivity.
Come on, you can do this.
Please, we want
one demo to work.
Come on, we can-- come
on, it's going to work.
ALEX RUSSELL: Jake,
why are you not online?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I am online.
But we've got conference Wi-Fi,
which is like being offline.
[APPLAUSE]
Maybe if I keep pressing this
button, something will happen.
ALEX RUSSELL: So
are you suggesting
that I shouldn't get
conference Wi-Fi for my house?
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
There's a somewhat
irony about a talk
devoted to making things
work offline fine has failed
due to a lack of connectivity.
ALEX RUSSELL: Mm, yeah,
we'll go with ironical.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
We can fight this.
We can fight.
We're going to give
it one more go.
ALEX RUSSELL: One more go, yeah?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I mean, the
white screen is not great.
I mean, that's not
what we intended.
What time were you up to last
night making all of these work?
ALEX RUSSELL: Let's
not talk about that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, that's fine.
Here we go.
ALEX RUSSELL: Also,
let's not define "work."
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, oh,
something happened there.
Right, OK, so we're
saying there's
some kind of connection.
ALEX RUSSELL: We're
not quite online.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Not quite online.
Is it half online?
How does this app
work half online?
ALEX RUSSELL: I'm not sure.
I'm not sure what that is.
We don't seem to be-- oh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
no, no, don't touch it.
Oh, that could have worked.
I'm going to push
this button again.
So we're worried about
our talk in the running.
I think we've
solved that problem.
Come on leader board.
You can do it.
I think we're going
to have to bail.
We're going to have to
bail on the second demo.
Maybe we can leave those there.
And if it starts to work again,
we can sort of pick up on that.
ALEX RUSSELL: We'll
leave those there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And show
all of the magic happening,
excellence.
ALEX RUSSELL: This
is what we get
for switching
Wi-Fi networks just
the minute before the talk.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly.
What would happen if I
ditched off the Wi-Fi network?
Do you think that would help?
ALEX RUSSELL: I don't know.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is the Wi-Fi
here worse than-- not Wi-Fi.
Oh, well no one told us that.
OK, let's--
ALEX RUSSELL: So no conference
Wi-Fi for the house then.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
go one more time.
That seems to be loading better.
Does the leader board load?
That's the big question.
It does.
ALEX RUSSELL: You seem
to be winning, sir.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But what
happens on your phone?
ALEX RUSSELL: That's a really
good question, isn't it?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Why
do you have no data?
What network are you on?
ALEX RUSSELL: Let's not
talk about that either.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You know,
I'm a very scientific person.
But I am using all of my psychic
magic powers to make this work.
Right, OK, I'm abandoning that.
We'll come back to
that when it works.
ALEX RUSSELL: When it works.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: "When" is
the word I'm going to use.
ALEX RUSSELL: When it works.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Thank you, Wi-Fi.
I have a whole session
in the sandbox tomorrow
that depends on
the Wi-Fi working.
Come along to that.
ALEX RUSSELL: Jake
Archibald, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: As soon
as you see that change,
we'll come back.
OK, so what you saw there was
absolutely amazing, right?
What we were hoping to demo for
you there is push messaging.
Like when I got a higher
score than everyone else,
it should have
told Alex about it
even though he had
the web page closed,
he had the browser closed.
And also what we're hoping
to do is have background sync
as well.
So like we were seeing
before, playing the game
without a connection,
that's fine.
But that means that
when the phone tries
to send the score to the server,
it's going to fail to do that.
But background sync
means it can try and send
that data later on.
So say I'm playing the
game without a connection,
and I improve my score,
the score updates request
goes to the ServiceWorker.
Because everything does.
And then, the
ServiceWorker tries
to forward that request
to the quiz server.
But without a connection,
that doesn't go so well.
Are you pulling a face there?
ALEX RUSSELL: [GASP] Oh my god.
Jake, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You
have a notification.
That's amazing.
Oh God, oh thank you, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And that's how you turn an
atheist into someone religious.
OK, but is there another
part of that demo
you would like to show me?
ALEX RUSSELL:
Well, I don't know.
I mean, I found out
about that finally
working from my watch,
which is pretty good.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: All
using technology, right?
That watch doesn't even
have a browser on it.
But we're using web technology
to send messages to it.
That's incredible.
Right, whew, I didn't
realize this talk
was going to be asynchronous.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
I didn't realize
it was going to nearly kill me.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So originally,
if we were offline,
the score would fail
to go up to the server,
even though it was going via
the ServiceWorker, just because
of a failure in connectivity.
But then, the page can
register for a background sync,
say, hey, I want some time
later on to do some stuff.
And then, even if
you close the page,
even if you close the browser,
when the phone regains
connectivity, even if I
close the page like that,
the ServiceWorker will start up.
And it will try again
to make the request.
And this time, it succeeds.
Because we've got connectivity.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, so
setting up that background
sync is actually really
simple despite what
the demos might look like.
So first, from our
[INAUDIBLE] page,
we try to post the user's score.
And if that doesn't work,
we catch the failure.
And so what we do is we
wait for the ServiceWorker
to be installed if it
hasn't been already.
From there, once we've got
a service worker registered,
we register for a one-off
background synchronization.
That'll happen some time
when the device thinks
it has connectivity and power.
You can also register
for synchronization
that runs on an interval.
The value you pass in
is the minimum interval.
This one is set to an hour.
But that means that it won't
happen any more frequently
than once an hour.
Heuristics are going to be
used in order to determine
that the right time
for this to happen
is based on how often
you use the application,
whether or not there's power,
how often the user uses
the site, when they
tend to use it,
connections date, all
kinds of crazy stuff
that we don't really have a
total easy to under formula
for.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, and if
we know that two background
syncs are sort of scheduled
for like 10 minutes apart,
they'll coalesce
into one so we can
reduce a lot of the battery
impact of these things.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right,
so of course you
don't get the background
synchronization for free.
The user will have to
grant you permission
to be able to do that.
And they'll be able
to revoke it later.
So it's a good thing
we guarded our request
behind that registration.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But if
they do grant permission,
over in your ServiceWorker, you
will start to get a sync event.
And you'll get an
ID for those so you
know which synchronization
you're dealing with.
Because you could have
one on an interval.
And you could have
a one-off one.
And once you get those, you can
do whatever you want, really.
Like in the
installation process,
you get this
event.waitUntil thing.
And you pass a promise into it.
And that defines length and
success of the synchronization.
If you give it back
a rejected promise,
it treats that as the
synchronization failed.
And it will be
rescheduled, even if it
was a one-off one like
sending the score.
If we signal that we
failed to do that,
it'll reschedule that
for some time later.
In terms of sending
the score, we're
going to get the score
from a database, which
could be IDB or whatever.
And we're just going to
use Fetch to post it up
to the server.
And if that fails,
the promise rejects.
And it will reschedule
the synchronization.
If we do get a
response back, we're
also going to look
at the status code.
If the status code isn't 200,
we're going to throw an error.
If you throw an error
within a promise chain,
that rejects the promise.
It does the same thing, which
will throw that rejection up
the chain into waitUntil.
And it will reschedule
the synchronization.
And that's it.
Using the Fetch API
makes this stuff
so much more simple
than XML HTTP
request, which is terrible.
So now the score
has successfully
reached the server.
ALEX RUSSELL: And at
that point, the server
knew that I had
lost first place.
So it told Google
Cloud Messaging,
which relayed it back
to the ServiceWorker
on my device, which decided
to show me a notification.
And I clicked that notification,
which sent a message back
to the--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: ServiceWorker.
ALEX RUSSELL: ServiceWorker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You
helped write this spec.
You need to remember it.
ALEX RUSSELL: Which responded by
opening up a page on my device.
So how did we set up
the push messaging?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Alex.
ALEX RUSSELL: Good
question, Alex.
From that page, you
want the registration
ID that you've been
sent from the server.
Just have it be
included with the page
or use an empty string if
it doesn't have one already.
From there, you can register
for push notifications.
If you've already
got one, you'll
get back the details of your
previous registration right
away.
Otherwise, the
browser will probably
ask the user for permission.
Assuming the
permission is granted,
you'll get back the registration
details from the promise
that you register with.
And then, the
registration details
give you an ID and a URL
that you can send back
to Google Cloud Messaging.
But other vendors are going to
use different systems for this.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yes, it's not a lock
into Google Cloud Messaging.
Every other vendor will have
its own messaging platform.
They're welcome to use Google's.
But I doubt Apple
will, for instance.
Now your server
can send messages
to GCM, which will then be
sent to the user's devices.
And this will wake
up the ServiceWorker
and fire a push event,
as you can see here.
And you'll get a little
bit of information
with that, just a very
small amount of information.
If you've done push messages
on native platforms before,
it's a very small
amount of information.
But it will be enough to tell
us that we've lost the lead.
If we needed more
information at this point,
we could go off to the
internet and fetch that stuff.
But in this case, we're just
going to do a new notification.
And this is a platform
native notification,
meaning it will show up
on your watch or whatever
as we saw in the demo.
So to use a tap
set notification,
you'll get another event inside
the ServiceWorker notification
click.
And in response to
this-- once again,
you can do what you want.
But we chose to navigate
to the leader board
to encourage the user to
see who they're losing out
to and by how much.
All of this stuff is
just using primitives.
You don't have to do
what we've shown today.
Take it apart.
Build something crazy with it.
The ServiceWorker
blows the doors
open to heaps of
new possibilities,
more than what we've
just talked about today.
I am genuinely really,
really excited about it.
Can I use it in
production today?
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
if you check out,
is ServiceWorker ready
yet, you will find out
the clear and
unequivocal answer is no.
But get ready.
A lot of this stuff is in
Canary already in some form.
And we're racing with Firefox
and other browser vendors
to get implementations
shipping as soon as possible.
But no matter who
wins that race,
we expect that the web will win.
And in fact, the network control
portions, the Fetch event,
that sort of thing,
are going to land
in a couple of months in Chrome.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
that's Chrome stable.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, background
sync and push and those sorts
of things are going to
take a little bit longer.
But there's going to be a steady
drumbeat of those coming soon.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
And you want to be
ready to start using these
things as soon as they land.
Because the ServiceWorker is
best used as an enhancement
to your site.
Because the first time
the user visits your site,
no one's going to
have a service worker,
even if the browser
supports them.
So they're very
much an enhancement.
So as soon as it lands in
browsers, it's useful to you.
Give its features just to the
browsers that support them.
And if you use very
simple feature detection,
your site will
work uninterrupted
in browsers that don't
support ServiceWorker.
ALEX RUSSELL: Right,
that's exactly what we
did with QuizApp that was built
by the Polymer team, not us.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
it didn't require
heaps of re-architecture.
I know when I was
at Lanyard, if we
wanted to do the
AppCache stuff, we
had to start a new m-dot site.
Because you had to
re-architecture everything
to use AppCache.
That is not true
with ServiceWorker.
ALEX RUSSELL: No,
they handed me an app.
And I made it work offline.
It was that easy.
But the second that this stuff
lands in Chrome, millions
of users are going to
have it accessible to them
across tons of devices.
And so now is the time
to start learning it.
And try to figure out
how it can benefit you
and your users and the sites
perhaps that you already
have deployed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Yes, and if you're
looking for some inspiration,
the W3 web mobile group
are currently compiling
ServiceWorker patents.
And they're looking
for contributors.
So if you want to start writing
demos, come up with use cases,
or see examples that
other people have made,
this is an absolutely
great place to do it.
ALEX RUSSELL: At Google, we
want the web to be first class.
We want it to be an
application platform
that you can use with
everything with a browser.
The ServiceWorker opens up
a ton of new possibilities.
And we've only shown
you a few of them today.
But we're really most
excited about what
you're going to go
out and do with it.
We can't wait to see
what you build next.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
I think we have a little
bit of time for questions
if anyone has any.
ALEX RUSSELL: Other than, how
did your demos go so well?
AUDIENCE: How did
your demos go so well?
ALEX RUSSELL: Practice.
AUDIENCE: So I
noticed that there
was no committed support
for IE and Safari yet.
Do you know the
reasons for that?
Are they working
on a separate spec?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
the question is,
what's the deal
with IE and Safari?
Mozilla has quite
heavily bought into it.
But where are the other guys?
ALEX RUSSELL:
Yeah, so obviously,
it's very difficult for me
to speak for my own team
sometimes, let
alone other vendors.
So what I can tell
you is that we've
had positive signs
out of Microsoft.
They've come and talked to us
at the public working group
meetings about
ServiceWorker specifically.
And we're encouraged by that.
But obviously, it's a question
that you should probably
ask them.
The great news is that
it is progressive.
So if you're building a thing
that works with ServiceWorkers,
because it has to work
on that first page load,
it's always going to
work across browsers.
So you should just
not build your stuff
to require ServiceWorkers
all the time.
But if you have a
local data model that's
doing synchronization
with a back-end,
you'll be in a good position
to take advantage of it
on all the browsers
that do have it.
Our hope is that by
shipping quickly and having
multi-browser
support, it's going
to create a drumbeat
of amazing things
that you build that will
sort of get everyone excited.
We sort of saw this
work with WebGL.
And I'm hoping for a similar
cadence, if not faster.
AUDIENCE: Hey Alex, I was
thinking about the web
component case specifically
and HTML imports.
When you use the
Fetch API, are we
going to provide affordances
so developers can granularly
listen to the loads internal
to that HTML import document?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
can I take that?
ALEX RUSSELL: Please do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
so the question is,
currently, it looks
like in examples we've
shown that you make a request
and you get the full response
back.
But we're wanting
to do something
more granular than that.
The stream spec is in process.
We want to ship
before then, so we've
detached them as a requirement.
On the request object,
you've got .body.
And at the moment,
it's this kind
of empty object as JSON as text.
But we're going to
convert that into a stream
when streams land.
And it's still going
to have those methods.
But they're just a shortcut
to consuming the entire stream
and converting it
to whatever format.
So you'll have a stream.
With the example with the
image, transcoding an image,
we want to be able to do that
with video, a fully live video
with no defined end point.
We want you to be able to take
a new image, a new video format,
transcode it within
the ServiceWorker,
and pipe it to the
browser using streams,
using transformation streams.
ALEX RUSSELL: So
the answer is, we
don't have a way to
do that right now.
The good news is that
if you know enough
about your
application structure,
you can usually predict what
you're going to need and put it
in caches preemptively.
And that's what the install
stuff is really about,
is making sure that
if there are things
that you know that
are dependencies,
you can capture them up front.
AUDIENCE: I have a question on
what kind of push technology
are you using to push the
asynchronous information back
to the device.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what push
technology were we using?
ALEX RUSSELL: That's GCM,
Google Cloud Messaging.
AUDIENCE: And that's
going to be the standard?
ALEX RUSSELL: Google
Cloud Messaging,
as part of the client
side being standardized,
the push server team
here has-- we've
been talking with them
about standardizing
some of the
northbound API areas.
That's an area that is
ripe for standardization.
But no one has committed
to anything yet.
If you talk to the other
push servers, what happens
is that the protocol on the
wire between the phone and GCM
is probably going
to remain something
that is going to be tied
deeply into the operating
systems of these devices in
order to maintain battery life.
But northbound protocols
between your application server
and your push messaging
server are the sort of thing
where people are starting
to have conversations.
And the API that exists
here on the phone
is going to be
absolutely standardized.
And that's something
that we've been
pushing to get
done very quickly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so I
know that you said
earlier some of the
pitfalls with AppCache.
But that does work in the
latest Internet Explorer
and current versions
of Firefox, et cetera.
So is there any way besides
user agent detection
of kind of using AppCache
when it's available,
and then using ServiceWorkers
when that's available?
Whereas ServiceWorkers, you
can detect that in JavaScript,
but you need to have the
AppCache header, which is--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the
question is, can you
use AppCache in
the browsers that
don't support ServiceWorker,
and use ServiceWorker
in the others?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, is there any way
besides using user detection?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So if you have
a service worker registered,
that effectively
clobbers the AppCache.
So you can have both in use
on the page at the same time.
You can have them
both on the page.
But the ServiceWorker will
take over from AppCache,
and it will become null.
So yeah, you have
them both on the page.
And AppCache will work
on the older browsers.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it
just won't use AppCache,
or will you have to
explicitly block the AppCache?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It
just won't work it.
It just won't use it.
AUDIENCE: OK,
awesome, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
about updating ServiceWorkers.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yes, so there's
a very long, very complicated
dance, which we didn't
do, either in the slides
or in the code.
But the basic idea
is that updating
is the worst and nastiest bit
of pretty much any product that
has to be always up to date.
Chrome goes to extreme
lengths to make sure
that you are always up to
date on the native client
side of things.
With regular websites, you
don't have that problem, right?
You're always fetching
from the server
as long as you haven't far
future expired something.
So you're always up to date.
So what we're doing
with ServiceWorker
is we're making sure
that you do you cache
the ServiceWorker in
all its dependencies.
But we check usually
when you go to that site.
And we request updates about the
freshness of the ServiceWorker
behind the back of the
ServiceWorker itself.
And we make sure that we do
that at least once every 24
hours if you're using the
app on a consistent basis.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It will
generally be once every request
unless you use HTTP caching
headers to push it longer.
ALEX RUSSELL: The
general idea here
is that you are going to
have an update model that
looks very much
like Chrome's where
if you close all
the tabs to a site,
and the ServiceWorker has
been downloaded and installed
behind you, the next
time you go to that site,
you'll get the freshest version.
And so there's a whole system
in place in the ServiceWorker
specification to make sure
that that works that way.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
like everything, it's
fully extensible.
So you can do what you want.
If you're the next
version in waiting,
the user can still use
the current version
while tabs are open.
But this new one does
have the opportunity
to just go and kick
the other one out.
Otherwise, it will wait
for-- but once you do that,
you will now be in
control of pages that
were loaded with
the old version.
ALEX RUSSELL: Did I mention
this was very complicated?
We can talk later.
It's very complicated
in the sense
that updating any live
code is very complicated.
And we're trying
to make this easy
and give you a
simple model for it.
But we can describe
it at length later.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: All right,
and I think-- oh, we
got one more from
the [INAUDIBLE].
Make it quick.
AUDIENCE: So for people
trying out ServiceWorkers,
do you have a good
place where you're
collecting all the feedback
and ideas and suggestions?
ALEX RUSSELL: It's
a good question.
So the specification
and a lot of the ideas
that had been poured into it so
far-- sorry, the question was,
how are we going to
be collecting feedback
about ServiceWorkers?
So a lot of the discussion has
moved to the public WebApps
mailing list at the W3C.
Because they're sort
of the organizing body
that has decided to take on
the standardization effort.
And that goes well.
But a lot of the
action is happening
on a GitHub repository.
If you search for
ServiceWorkers,
I think it might be the
first or second hit.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So that first URL
there is to the
status page that says
which parts or which browsers.
There is a link to the
spec from there as well.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, and
so file issues there.
We do look at them.
We are triaging them.
Or send an email
to Public WebApps.
And we will give it a look.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Excellent, I think
we're definitely out of time.
So thank you very
much, everyone.
Cheers.
ALEX RUSSELL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]